hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm ryan
right I'm road right welcome to the real
regional dick the ballad not a dick the
dick this is Jerry and Sally and were
the real rejects and the real rejects
are gonna do a little special for you
today a lot of people have been asking
for shoutouts a lot i have over a
hundred fifty requests so let me first
start off by saying this someone
actually unsubscribe yeah because they
didn't get a shout-out when they wanted
one you know i deem that not a true fan
not a true fan some people got on this
guy's ass and i think that guy and
deserve it okay if you're gonna
unsubscribe because of it you don't get
a shoutout why what did you subscribe to
the channel just because you wanted
someone to shout out your name this is
why we can't have nice things we go in
order of shout out requests it's that
simple so keep in mind that you're not
the only one who asked for one so if you
don't hear your name today just doesn't
mean I'm not gonna give you a shout as I
mean we're not gonna give you one it
just means you're not up yet on the list
just think about it we have thousands of
people watching these videos so the list
is a little bit long and it's gonna get
longer like some things like right now
when i turn my head to sally something
is have just extended oh your IQ wait so
to look upon you is to become more
intelligent that's exciting okay you
knows the answers still yes you see
anything else your eyes are pretty cool
like the design oh thank you is it so
sweet yeah but i always thank you wow i
just eyes are so pretty and it's nice
and someone things minor free yeah yeah
yeah that gets my dick hard okay so
let's do this wow what i charge the
battery for 45 minutes you have another
battery no Jesus Chris all right guys
here we go shout out time let's do this
hmm dark Hokies 154 you said that I
inspired you to create a YouTube channel
my friend yeah that's cool that's really
sweet of you dark okage you I don't know
what to hook it I don't know either who
caused who caused yay that sounds like a
Japanese thing are you Japanese are you
a dark Japanese person are you half
black half Japanese which is always a
good mix very sexy stuff very into it
necessary
you're very strong picture someone comes
at me for a racist joke you said a KFC
joke on a black person Jim listen listen
people need to know I'm half black so
it's fine if I do it I won't talk about
KFC anymore I promise yeah that was the
problem did you talk about games either
88 junkie 1984 you wanted one just from
me so you got it Oh 3d junkie I just
responded to comment for him I like that
man because it mean when I mad when I'm
stoned it feels like everything's in 3d
well the whole you're already in 3d
everything is already tournament is it
yeah dude Sally you just blew my mind I
like those uh those HD vision sunglasses
they sell come like life is already it's
already be like why do you just because
you're tinting it yellow slightly a
plane ah well 3d junkie this is your
shoutout from Sally no Sally weren't you
showing your cleavage today for 3d
junkie huh I can't because I'm not
wearing anything that next time I'm
sorry 3d junkie I'm sorry I mean you can
see them but you can't like I don't know
sorry I'm making like tell me you and go
please why were they satisfied when you
got me he's hoping in him can dress yeah
I'm hoping they'll go further Fox gaming
he said you know you want to give a
shout-out uno dos tres Vasya no more you
said that you knew that we wanted to
give you a shout out so I don't know how
you're a mind reader like that good job
Fox gaming good job star force star fox
I was talking about Star Fox oh my gosh
his yesterday so many memories that was
my jam yeah do a barrel roll gee I've
been saved by Fox house way
it's okay slippy always got in the way
this little girl you got in trouble no
Pepe was the the rabbit okay yeah slippy
was always a nuisance I could never get
to Mars I got tomorrow yeah in order to
beat the game you got to get to Mars I
never got but there are alternate routes
you can take I forget which ones are
shared I want them to make an epic like
Star Fox they should make a star fox
movie and it should be written by fox
gaming yeah buddy so do it get on do it
we're right into the premiere or
something yeah dude suck your penis if
you're a guy I hope you're a guy yes I
can suck something and we'll give it a
great review unless we don't like it in
which case we mysteriously won't do
already Nikolai balinsky said I'm super
sweet whatever that means I meant a
thing he meant swag swag with the type
of yeah dude get first off learn how to
type better okay if you're gonna
compliment me I expect these compliments
to be top notch compliments requests
shout outs better yeah request them
better please seriously dude whatever
your name is Nikolai Belinsky you're
good you're good but thank you you're
awesome Nikolai I agree I've never met a
nickel I i think i have actually was he
german is it a joke is that something
that we just ask you doing what is your
in morbi yeah i like to know people's
everything's more a [ __ ] why i think
we'd be more more of a Russian or more
of a gothic mmm ethnicities say a lot
about someone like Sally had a right of
your block you like KFC oh if you're
Chinese you love Jackie champ I'm doubt
yeah it's that simple it's that simple
if you're Italian Godfather's your
favorite movie that might be true action
well I'm Italian to my favorite it's
garlic bread I consider that a food like
that is its own it is a figment like
iconic here yeah part of the pyramid
part of the garlic bread is in a
different box than the rest of wheat and
bread tree dad son shoot that son well
Nikolai thanks for getting us in touch
with our roots appreciate that buddy
Tyrone Hamilton Tyrone you said that
devil will take your soul yeah real here
is this like a binding contract sort of
thing or like what if we want the devil
to take your soul what for an [ __ ]
we're just a musician those are so
little devils he can become famous yeah
like that's Saturday Night Live sketch
yeah I mean like what are you doing
getting involved with those kinds of
people
should not you know yeah I didn't break
out of it if you can and invite them to
our channel so you can worship us and so
see ya like I think the least of your
troubles at this point is a shout out if
you've got Satan up and down your door
yeah my why is Satan on your ass right
now you should you know you should set
some affairs in order I don't think
we're on your top priority list this
void but you got you shout out anyway do
you need Jesus you need Jesus goodness
you need Jesus Mitchell Richardson Mitch
boys name that was like a Tracy Morgan
impression trying to be Arnold
Schwarzenegger yeah Mitchell just turned
14 guys ah he's a big fan of our channel
oh really that's cool I got say
something though man if your parents are
allowing you to watch your parents need
to do better monitoring long he's always
in his home he's probably is a nice do
you say 13 or 14 14 yeah well he's in
like eighth grade for teens the age
where you learn how to use computers
better than the people who are older
than you and they start getting into all
kinds of things that you arguably
shouldn't yeah I wonder how many of our
subscribers are actually like 14 year
olds I mean probably that makes sense
why they gravitate towards all the penis
jokes i mean people love penis joke
people love a good penis joke ahead
lowes penis in general isn't that right
Sally hmm ok on the count of three Jerry
let's whip out our penis one two three I
was weary to do first man what did you
know i do it for your gonna do it first
i mean if we're doing this you have to
do it first come on solid you want
sheriff eNOS you didn't even ask me if i
wanted to about my penis oh don't ever
say that again why me now I'm curious
hey you know we're a progressive shown
happy birthday but I'm very offensive I
can't Luke Williams he said he wanted a
shout out to you cuz this also his
birthday hey okay I have a surprise for
you I am your mother it's like I'm 70s
blaxploitation strong yeah and your mama
I am Luke Luke could you mom what the
[ __ ]
so yeah happy birthday he'll be laughed
that was our gift to you as our gift of
joke yeah it is Joe thank you for your
birthday here's a joke one time I went
to with Jerry to chuck e cheese on my
birthday really hey PA want a google
ticket and we invited Lauren invited
Alyssa we've ever had I want to do my
18th birthday ah you should have this
before you met me it was it was right
around the time we started getting to
know each other I wanna have like a like
an office team building exercise and
chuck e cheese have like a bunch of 30
and 40 year old like slacks and ties
wearing people and at Chuck E Cheese to
exhume together they get ticket and Luke
Williams will be there yeah yeah well
way to go looky happy birthday Luke
please you're gone I'm not he'll be
there Sally you'll be there okay I'll be
thinking about you and then I'll relax
after I'm done thinking about you go on
like Halloween it's fine Jackie she's
awesome dish is the one I go to woo same
for a bigger prize Edmund mcginley he
said you wanted one from Sally Sally
shut him out Jerry leave the frame Evan
McKinley on what have you I have a
question is Edmund mcginley related to
jhansi McKinley because I love that guy
so if he's like your dad or your uncle
you tell him what's up yeah Jerry you
know what me and Brian already met him
so to see you buddy he's really sweet
that's messed up yeah no way he's
awesome so he has a kid who's mentally
challenged actually and Sally got to
meet him yeah I did okay cuz i worked at
the Boys and Girls Club at my high
school and so I volunteered there and so
I used to play with him and then one day
John see we can li gave me a handshake
it was like thank you for hands yeah
won't you my dad must be nice taunting
mentally challenged kids it was not no
it's ok Sally it's ok you please guitar
very well but that's probably Edmund all
right hey one of the dudes from from uh
spider-man video told me to tell you
ryan right Nick mock told me to tell you
you're a cool chicken nugget ah chicken
nuggets yeah hmm thanks man I'm it did
myself and BBQ sauce in
Robinson honey try it FML ranch sweet
and sour sauce to everything do you
think's thanks man thanks for letting me
know that great thanks you're a good
mcchicken kissed Stefan junka give me up
for a shout out so what's up thanks for
watching that Spidey review thanks man
you're good good you're cool you're a
cool guy cool guy like idiot i am the
battery's gonna die again because i am
the master of not charging the battery
let's see here youssef ash shroff
indonesian subscriber he's a big-time
fan of the channel yeah your comments
all the time what's up Yousef what's up
yourself yeah sup Rama what's going on
there oh we got you Rama's oh man I'm
gonna raid your home berandal status
whatever that means I'm gonna go all
gangster on your ass that's what I'm
gonna do yeah you basically said I'm I
go I'll gangster and raid your house
steal all your [ __ ] last person Taylor
Houston checking out our older videos a
lot you're a cool person man you're big
fan of channel really appreciate all the
love and support you've been giving man
I wanted in the sauce is staring up by
saying Taylor I want to suck your dick
that's what's gonna happen it's like you
at the end of the year you're gonna
start like an awards show when this
channel picks up enough steam and you're
gonna give up with little golden dank
Awards yeah I was like a sculpture of
your dick yeah one time God appeared to
me in a dream and told me that's what I
have to do similar to when Noah was told
to build the ark he said you have to
give out golden dick statues I feel like
God was just trolling you you should
have like like my god style you should
give like dick awards to movies but then
you should have one reserved for like
fan of the year ah yeah the golden dick
shadow and i will have balls on it yeah
anyway guys that's it for our
subscribers shoutouts for today okay
doesn't mean it's the last one doesn't
mean its last one so if you guys haven't
gotten yours yeah just know you're on
the list still and we're coming around
to you on the lid you're on the list my
lips are you on the list you on the lid
if you're gonna get into the club you
got again the list alright that simple
or unless you have cleavage though
Celia's great boobs I've spied on her so
many times and I've been able to see
them it's very fantastic matches with
her hair you never know you haven't yeah
yeah yeah I have a man that doesn't seem
right nevermind it might not seem right
nothing seems right that comes out of
his mouth as if his last name right
right anyway guys that's that's it for
today if you're new to the channel
subscribe subscribe people if you kind
of want to check out my channel you can
subscribe yeah hit her boobs hit them
because it could be you on here next
time yeah it was good you know be cool
to bring a subscriber on the channel
sometimes yeah one day living away and
you're a big fan of the channel hit us
up maybe I'll bring you over to my place
yeah I think of them like a like a
school like Oprah does whenever
someone's on you oh yeah lion you get a
[ __ ] yeah you get a [ __ ] and you
get a [ __ ] Oh totally suck all our
fans did yeah and I gotta mention her
what's up Michelle Fernandez how you
doing girl love Michelle for name on the
mug with michelle for name internet
romance internet romance that's what we
created we're like the notebook but
online yes yeah p the blog he said yeah
I'd really a great nope I don't know a
catfish is you Gavin yeah well tune in
next time will we get more shout outs at
the end of our videos thanks for
watching yeah you stay classy San Diego
and you know indonesian primarily san
diego in Indonesia or worse from